we have all new details about the
argument that led to a child abuse
investigation against Brad Pitt new
evidence is surfaced and there is
insight that could sway this case the
FBI tells ET it is continuing to gather
facts about the reported child abuse
allegations against Brad Pitt here's the
question at the center of the dispute
was the alleged incident abuse or just a
typical father-son spat here's what we
know now the investigation news broke
after Angelina filed for divorce late
Monday asking for full custody of the
couple's six children
it seems the filing was prompted at
least in part by an incident that
happened on a family flight home from
Europe last Wednesday here are the new
details pitt and Jolie were flying from
France to Southern California their jet
believed to be a bomb Adair global
Express like this one stopped to refuel
in International Falls Minnesota a
source familiar with the situation tells
ET Brad had an argument with their 15
year old son Maddox that source is
defending Brad saying there was no
inappropriate physical contact
emphasizing this was totally a child
parent disagreement sources tell ET that
there are images being shopped around of
Brad on the tarmac there allegedly Pitt
can be seen on video looking drunk and
yelling et has reached out to confirm
the authenticity of this alleged video
Brad and Angie's jet flew on to Burbank
California upon landing the pilot had a
quick chat with air traffic control
where'd you come from
[Music]
exactly yeah we have to behave brother
originated me but we've done
international calls it Minnesota all for
the first place Brad is gearing up for
what already is in an ugly divorce
battle he's hired Lance Spiegel a
high-powered Hollywood divorce attorney
Spiegel rep Charlie Sheen during his
custody battle
with Denise Richards and Eva Longoria
during her split from Tony Parker we're
told Brad isn't ready to give up custody
of his kids and is frustrated by what he
calls a quote smear campaign being
lodged against him
[Music]